la proposition de loi dite de sécurité
globale a provoqué de vives réactions en
france parmi les dispositifs les plus
décriées le désormais célèbre article 24
imaginé pour protéger l'intégrité des
forces de l'ordre mais dénoncé par
beaucoup comme portant atteinte à la
liberté d'informer à la suite de
plusieurs jours de débats et de
contestation dans la rue
le chef de file de la majorité
présidentielle a annoncé lundi sa
réécriture
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui le
choix légistique que nous avons fait à
laisser s'installer un trouble si ce
n'est même la conviction parmi la
population que le droit d'informer que
le droit à l'information que l'exercice
même du contrôle légitimes des actions
de police étaient menacés
l' équilibre que nous avons recherché
sur cet article 24 n'a pas été
unanimement perçue contact insuffisant
pour calmer les opposants au texte qui
souhaitent son retrait pur et simple
c'est également la tonalité du côté de
plusieurs experts indépendants auprès de
l'onu qui tire la sonnette d'alarmé la
simple réécriture de l'article 24 ne
résoudra pas ses défauts et cette
disposition n'est certainement pas la
seule dans la proposition de loi qui
porte atteinte aux droits de l'homme si
le débat public s'est focalisé sur cet
article 24 la proposition de loi prévoit
d'autres dispositifs également mis à
l'index par ce même rapport
l'article 22 autorisant l'utilisation de
drones de surveillance au nom de la
sécurité et de la lutte contre le
terrorisme permettrait une surveillance
étendue en particulier des manifestants
cela aura de graves implications pour le
droit à la vie privée la liberté de
réunion pacifique et la liberté
d'expression dans le pays des
préoccupations exprimées par un collège
d'experts indépendants qui travaillent
donc auprès du conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu il y a plusieurs jours
déjà la commission européenne avait fait
part de ses réserves concernant cette
loi de sécurité globale inquiétude
exprimée aussi par des ong par la
commission nationale consultative des
droits
l'homme et c'est dans ce contexte avec
un sens du timing qui interroge que le
compte twitter de la france à l'onu a
publié cette allocution d' emmanuel
macron les circonstances exceptionnelles
engendrés par la pandémie menace par
ailleurs dans de nombreux pays
l'acquis de plus de 70 ans de combat
international en faveur des droits de
l'homme
la pandémie de noix pas servir de
prétexte aux restrictions de l'espace de
la société civile recul de l'état de
droit aux atteintes à la liberté
d'expression à la détention arbitraires
d'opposants
pas sûr que le message soit bien reçu au
moment même où la france est pointée du
doigt par les instances internationales
cela avait d'ailleurs déjà été le cas
l'an passé lorsque la haut commissaire
aux droits de l'homme de l'onu avait
demandé des comptes au sujet des
violences policières lors des
manifestations des gilet jaune et en
dépit des récusations du porte parole du
gouvernement
voici une énième illustration de ses
inquiétudes à l'étranger
cette une du dernier numéro de courrier
international
le président de la république qui est
présenté sous un aspect autoritaire avec
cette légende la presse étrangère
s'inquiète du virage sécuritaire pris
par emmanuel macron